[Musique]
laurent fabius et michel giraud sont
décidés à mettre tout en oeuvre pour
obtenir l'implantation de disneyland à
marne-la-vallée c'est ce qui ressort de
l'entretien qu'ils ont eu cet après midi
à matignon
point essentiel la mise en place dès
septembre d'un processus commun de
négociation est à région avec pour
corollaire immédiat
la nomination dès la première quinzaine
de septembre des négociateurs manière
subtile
c'est dans la zone la moins peuplée de
marne la vallée à une trentaine de
kilomètres à l'est de paris
que serait construit ce fameux
disneyland mais pour l'instant tout
reste au conditionnel
fin janvier laurent fabius recevait le
vice président de walt disney
productions au car le bungee rno depuis
peu de choses ont percé des négociations
entre la société américaine et le
gouvernement et on ne sait pas où en
sont ces négociations les atouts de la
france deux aéroports internationaux 27
millions de touristes par an et surtout
sa situation géographique au coeur de
l'europe les atouts de l'espagne le
soleil et 43 millions de touristes
chaque année
[Musique]
en ce qui concerne l'espagne en parlait
au début d'une implantation à barcelone
ensuite ce fut alicante
en fait le site n'est pas encore
déterminé ce serait le long de la
méditerranée
du côté de valence si l'espagne choisi
walt disney productions il prévoit un
village gigantesque sur le modèle du
disneyland d'anaheim en californie ou de
celui de tokyo
ouvert il ya deux ans en revanche si la
france l'emportent il s'agirait selon
l'hebdomadaire newsweek d'un centre
epcot une vitrine des technologies
futures comme il en existe déjà une en
floride à proximité de disney world
les attractions plus traditionnels comme
celle de disney world côtoieraient
cependant ce parc de loisirs pour
adultes de chaque côté des pyrénées
c'est donc la surenchère l'enjeu est de
taille
on parle de 20 mille créations d'emplois
à terme ce serait pour la france
outre une relance du tourisme une
promotion de l'industrie française et
pour la région une réponse à la volonté
de rééquilibrer à l'est mais ça coûte
très cher à lui seul l'aménagement
reviendrait à des minières de front dans
les américains demandent le maximum de
subventions publiques et de prêts
bonifiés en france en attendant la
décision finale région ita s'interrogent
sur leur participation financière comme
en état et régions se répartir est il
les charges dues aux infrastructures
prolongé par exemple le rer jusqu'au
site ne serait pas une mince affaire
tout ça bien sûr dans l'expectative de
la réponse de l'oncle d'amérique euro
disneyland est né en tout cas l'acte été
signée ce matin par le premier ministre
et le président de la royal disney
productions michael eisner ce parc sera
donc située à une quarantaine de
kilomètres à l'est de paris a marre de
la vallée nous reviendrons dans un
instant sur l'historique du projet est
ce qu'il va développer et puis sur la
colère des forains aussi qu'ils se
sentent menacer mais qui ont en partie
obtenu satisfaction en satisfaction de
jacques chirac ce matin au moment de la
signature d'ailleurs alors l'ouverture
du parc est prévu pour 1992 et ce sera
là de premier centre de loisirs de ce
genre en europe
il a fallu près de deux années de
travail et de négociations christophe
martet un dossier volumineux pour un
accord original
c'est la première fois en effet que les
pouvoirs publics signe un contrat
d'équipement avec une entreprise privée
un accord obtenu après 15 mois de
négociations difficiles entre français
et américains
tout commence en décembre 85 ans le site
de marne-la-vallée en concurrence avec
barcelone est retenu pour l'implantation
d'un euro disneyland le 18 décembre
laurent fabius signent un protocole
d'accord avec le pdg de disney le
premier ministre de l'époque souhaite
boucler le projet en trois mois
c'est compter sans l'appétit des
américains la disney company ne laisse
rien au hasard
demande et obtient toujours plus de la
france notamment sur le financement et
l'aménagement du parc d'attractions les
pouvoirs publics de leur côté tenant
beaucoup à ce projet créateur d'emplois
y'avait des promesses qui avaient été
faites lorsque le précédent gouvernement
a avalisé les propositions qui avaient
été faites dans mon prédécesseur
ces propositions et promesses elles ont
été tenues ce qui était bien naturel
parce que ça faisait partie d'un
équilibre d'ensemble amené le rer à
l'entrée du pas faire des prêts bonifiés
de la caisse des dépôts baisser les taux
le taux de la tva sur les tickets
d'entrée pour cela il a fallu un certain
nombre de décisions importantes assez
difficile à prendre pour une bonne
poignée de dollars la france accueillera
mika sur son sol
ouverture prévue le royaume enchanté
d'euro disneyland en 92 dans un an jour
pour jour donald et mickey ouvriront
leurs portes au public à marne-la-vallée
un an de cet événement euro disney a
accueilli journalistes et caméras pour
une visite de chantier
une visite vous allez voir mener à
l'américaine reportage huet et claude du
sud
les américains aiment les dates symbole
euro disney ouvre ses portes dans un an
jour pour jour les organisateurs ont
tenu à ce que ça se sache
résultat une journée où rien n'a été
laissé au hasard journalistes escorté
par des casses même aux miches à pont ni
hôtesses bottes et casque pour tous
fanfare à l'américaine et en prime la
présence du neveu de walt disney disney
bref une organisation à l'image de ce
chantier de 2000 hectares démesurée
quelques chiffres pour mesurer l'ampleur
du projet plus de 180 entreprises
cinq mille trois cents ouvriers français
espagnol italien allemand qui travaille
sans relâche pas question de transiger
sur la date d'ouverture
une soixantaine l'embauchent par semaine
à terme
euro disney devrait employer douze mille
personnes plus de 5000 chambres
réparties sur six hôtels disneyland
hôtel séquoia lo jay and hotel et cetera
construction d'une ligne directe rer et
d'une gare tgv
bref de quoi accueillir 11 millions de
visiteurs venus de tous les pays
d'europe
un dernier chiffre l'investissement se
monte à 55 milliards mirapolis et le
parc d'astérix ne joue pas dans la même
cour et 35 ans
que nous exerçons notre métier on
al'avantage énorme d'avoir hérité de
tous ces personnages pas mal tu disais à
créer un mythe et ses communicants
seulement en europe et dans le monde
ce quatrième monde enchanté de disney
difficile encore de l'imaginer
aujourd'hui pour un adulte en tout cas
car pour un enfant une marionnette
suffit
[Musique]
le sommeil de la belle au bois dormant a
été troublée aujourd'hui par le bruit de
la parade et de nombreuses équipes de
télévision six mois tout juste avant
l'ouverture d'eurodisney à
marne-la-vallée son château qui l'une
des principales attractions du parc de
loisirs a été inauguré en début d'après
midi il y avait beaucoup de monde des
petits fours et au milieu c'est bingo
remis et abdel joudi j'ai le plaisir je
l'avais l'orée du jeu rude au présent on
nous avait promis du spectacle on n'a
pas été déçu la parade les confettis les
ballons à la démesure d'une organisation
toutes américaines pensent et 2000
invités triés sur le volet et un bon
millier de journalistes venus du monde
entier à chouchouter promotion du parc
oblige
vous savez il faut créer un suspense et
le suspense est que à partir
d'aujourd'hui le parc les fermer
quelques donc vous même qui ne pourrait
le revoir closerie 92 le spectacle était
aussi dans la rue un peu surréaliste la
visite du plus grand chantier d'europe
après eurotunnel qui laisse la presse on
peut rappeler que voulez vous ce sont
les risques du métier
les 3000 cas semaine leur pardon les
employés disney se rode peu à peu au
sourire mehdi l'american cheese
côté attractions le royaume de la magie
est aussi celui de l'artifice les
rochers sont crevés déception le château
de la belle au bois dormant et en béton
et même les enfants ne se laisse pas
abuser par mickey et compagnie
[Musique]
c'est vrai c'est pas seulement des
attractions
c'est aussi un type de sociétés
particulièrement se fait un peu peur
mais bon chaque image ça fait peur pas
de soucis côté visiteurs le centre
d'information disney ouvert en décembre
a déjà accueilli cent mille curieux et
la vente des tickets d'entrée marche
fort avec des réservations pour l'an
nick et peut dormir sur ses deux
oreilles commencer bien sûr par
l'ouverture d'euro disneyland le royaume
de mickey a accueilli ce matin ses
premiers visiteurs avec une heure
d'avancé mingorance des voix aux
adorateurs de la ci dessous d'une vraie
famille française de villepin la
première à être présentée au guichet ce
matin grâce à mickey et la gagner
austérité et surtout un abonnement à vie
au royaume magique
comme elle des milliers d'anonymes venus
de toute l'europe ont fait le siège du
parc dès 6h ce matin
impatients de découvrir ce nouveau monde
à l'américaine
bienvenue au monde magic d'euro
disneyland pas plus organisés que mickey
une trentaine de caisses des sourires on
ouvre les portes une heure avant et le
tour est joué
225 francs d'entrée c'est cher mais le
rêve ça n'a pas de prix
un cadeau pour la figure
peut-être on l'espère se rappeler un peu
de jazz
on a vu aux états unis et voilà mais
c'est magnifique
donc on a voulu être là aujourd'hui pour
le premier jour retrouver l'enfant
une joie on est vraiment comment et tant
pis pour les esprits chagrins cette
amérique de rêves colorés déguisé peuplé
de fées de personnages de dessins animés
les européens en redemande
dépaysement assuré par 29 attraction
très bien rodé ils étaient venus pour
les gosses ils sont sous le charme
subjugué par le souci du détail de la
machine 10 idées ça me paraissait de
l'enfantin peu foire de pacotille je
trouve que c'est très bien
à beaumont agréable dr bah moi je me
bats la maladie
enchanté comme les organisateurs qui
affiche ce soir un sourire satisfait
mais refuse de communiquer le nombre
d'entrées par superstition ce soir
l'oncle picsou va faire ses comptes bien
réel en espérant que le bouche à oreille
marche à fond et que la petite souris tu
gagne son pari de 11 millions de
visiteurs par an
et tout d'abord la dernière histoire de
mickey la petite souris qui broyait du
noir et qui s'est mise en rouge
euro disney vient en effet d'autoriser
le vin dans les restaurants du parc
d'attractions une première qui rompt
avec la tradition sobriété en vigueur
chez disney est derrière tout cela bien
sûr c'est une nouvelle opération
séduction de la clientèle européenne qui
boude un peu milk et christelle meyrals
ils devaient les dernières attractions
d'eurodisney son temps peu plus
française vins bières et champagne ont
fait leur apparition
une véritable petite révolution chez
[ __ ] car lors de la création du parc
il ya plus d'un an
l'alcool avaient été bannis dont le
royaume pury magique de mickey pas la
moindre goutte n'avaient droit de cité
mais voilà française européens ont
contesté ce régime sec
il en avait assez de voir partout des
tonneaux alléchant sans pouvoir même
boire une bière et commettent disney les
rêves paraît-il devienne réalité
l'alcool est désormais autorisé à bas
bruit bois pour de bon sens va un petit
peu malheureux non
non on épouse est venu avec avec ma
fille déjà disney m'a dit on peut pas en
boire devant resteront alors dit jamais
je resterai là on a près la par la radio
que vous pouvez maintenant consommé de
l'alcool alors je suis aujourd'hui vrai
ça fait la digestion
l'autorisation d'alcool correspond à la
nouvelle stratégie commerciale de disney
le parquet était européenne is et pour
mieux répondre aux goûts de la clientèle
zorro côtoie désormais [ __ ] pour
autant l'alcool reste tout juste toléré
il est servi dans le restaurant chic du
parc mais pas dans les buvettes ou les
buffets nous allons réserver la
proposition de vin au restaurant qui
servent à la place car c'est plus le
complément traditionnel une nourriture
gastronomique plutôt que de la
nourriture qu'ils fassent faune qui
s'accommode pas forcément bien reste que
le vin a fait son entrée à disney une
sacrée entorse au règne du coca roi
boire un petit coup c'est agréable dans
les cafés de paris comme dans le royaume
magique
nous allons coulisses maintenant on
pourrait découvrir les animaux les
animaux qui ont une place très
importante dans les spectacles les
parades disneyland
il symbolise bien sûr les personnages
créés par disney lui-même les animaux
qui sont chouchoutés par un personnage
un personnage que nous présente
élise avait été gelée et jean leloup
faire un câlin bien agréable pourtant ce
n'est pas un bon gros toutou c'est un
loup depuis cinq ans lionel carembault
s'occupe de bêtes sauvages mais aussi
deux chèvres dame de chevaux et de bien
d'autres espèces
il est responsable des 600 animaux des
disneyland paris
cette passion m'est venu sur le tard
parce qu'un jour ça fini a eu envie d'un
pigeon blanc
j'étais persuadé que les pigeons blancs
existait j'étais persuadé que les
voyageurs blanc bail en avait déjà
et puis je me suis rendu compte qu'ils
n'avaient pas je me suis formé donc en
génétique j'ai mis cinq ans pour
blanchir une souche de pigeons voyageurs
faye à blanchir arriver à avoir ce que
vous avez vu aujourd'hui des pigeons
blancs purs
400 pigeons voyageurs s'envole d'ici
plusieurs fois par jour mais pas pour un
long voyage dans dix minutes
guidés par leur instinct ils auront
rejoint leur volière par leur part de
leurs vues à l'autre sujet de fierté
pour lionel son écurie de percherons la
plus grande d'europe 31 chevaux de trait
à la stature impressionnante
il participe à tour de rôle à la parade
du bossu de notre-dame suivant un emploi
du temps très strictes
c'est des chevaux qui ont aplani
exactement comme comme nous ils ont des
jours de repos par semaine y travaillent
cinq jours donc par semaine deux heures
et demie par jour pas plus trois heures
on va dire grand maximum deux mois de
vacances dans la lettre puisqu'il
repartent dans les prairies du perche et
mis son nez de moi j'ai un espèce de
roulement 10 fait
[Musique]
pour djeli la chèvre d'esmeralda c'est
différent pas question de roulement ni
de remplaçante
il y a trop d'affinités entre hal et sa
maîtresse s'est traduite à la naissance
beau succès donc maintenant même si
comme à quoi un petit chien en fait dans
le ranch davy crockett les loups aussi
sont comme des petits chiens
ceux là sont tous frères et soeurs et
les premiers mois de leur vie ils les
ont passés dans la maison de lionel un
famille avec ses enfants
mais attention ça reste d'y louer un
comportement d'animal sauvage sais pas
c'est pas c'est pas le petit caniche qui
vit sur une banquette ou sur la moquette
il restera de toute façon dans ses gènes
et il faut qu'il reste absolument à nous
donc il faut avoir un comportement
vigilant avec avec 600 animaux à charge
lionel prend peu de vacances ce n'est
pas comme les rênes 11 mois de congé
pour eux ils ne travaillent qu'en
décembre pour promener le père noël et
puis sachez que c'était la fête
aujourd'hui à eurodisney le parc de
marne-la-vallée célèbre est en effet son
cinquième anniversaire des réjouissances
partagée par des milliers d'invités et
qui se sont terminées ce soir par un
immense feu d'artifice précédé comme
chaque soir par la parade électrique m
et parmi les moments forts de cette
journée bien on retiendra celui où la
chanteuse barbara hendricks a entonné un
vibrant et piepers berre bon
anniversaire à mickey
pour andy
[Musique]
pas
[Applaudissements]
brady
[Musique]
à
et
[Applaudissements]
où
[Musique]
regardez son statut de destination
favorite de pourvoyeur de grand frisson
on disneyland paris va inaugurer une
nouvelle attraction la tour de la
terreur soit cm de haut qui reproduit un
hôtel délabré grâce à cette tour le pape
espère attirer plus de 20 millions de
visiteurs par an sensations fortes
garanties
reportage gély à beaumont et m'a dit
diawara décrit dès l'entrée du parc
à l'intérieur de ces tours de 54 mètres
de hauteur un ascenseur un peu
particulier une chute à 45 kilomètres
heure
si vite que pendant quelques instants
les passagers sont en état d'apesanteur
[Musique]
tu as tellement quand même un village
quand même une bonne chute dans le vide
on a l'impression de tomber d'une grande
tour et ça c'est impressionnant vrai ça
très agréable
j'avais peur mais trois ans de travaux
plus de 60 millions d'euros
d'investissements un décor entièrement
reconstituée façon années 40
thème de cette attraction la quatrième
dimension un concept importé des états
unis la tour de la terre a été réfléchi
pensé avait il ya douze ans
résultat aujourd'hui presque une heure
d'attenté malgré la pluie
de quoi relancer le walt disney studios
le second parc disney un peu à la traîne
en moyenne chaque personne dépenses 40
euros dans les boutiques de nouvelles
attractions pour plus de visiteurs nous
étions à 12 millions 500 mille entre
elles puis ensuite 12 millions ils
s'ennuient nous sommes à 14 millions
cinq cent mille ans créé en 2007
vous voyez que la progression est tout à
fait significatif derrière disney les
autres parcs français réagissent astérix
et le futuroscope prépare aussi de
nouvelles attractions
[Musique]